THE SECRETARY WILL CALL THE
ROLL. WELL, SHE DID. ALAN. I
WROTE A GILL ARCH ILETO. ASHBY.
ATKINS BECKER. BLAKE SPEAR.
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. ORTEZ E.
DOLLY! DODD. THERE WAS Ó.
HAGMAN GLASER, AS ALWAYS. OR
DATO. JONES LAIRD LIMÓN MCGUIRE.
MANY OF OUR MAIN NEWMAN WHEN
NILO KOBO PODIUM, PORTANTINO.
ROTH. RUBIO SEYARTO TOÀN SKINNER
. SMALL QUIVERS STERN HAMBURG,
WAHA WIENER WILK. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND OUR
GUESTS. BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY, PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LED IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
OUR CHAPLAIN, SISTER MICHELE
GORMAN, AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. SO
LET US BRING OUR MINDS AND
HEARTS INTO GOD'S PRESENCE
AGAIN. GRACIOUS GOD. BE WITH US
AS WE GLANCE IN OUR AT THE
WONDERS OF OUR WORLD. THOSE
WONDERS. MARY OLIVER CALLS THE
MYSTERIES SHE SAYS. TRULY WE
LIVE WITH MYSTERIES TOO
MARVELOUS TO BE UNDERSTOOD. HOW
GRASS CAN BE NOURISHING IN THE
MOUTHS OF THE LIMBS. RIVERS AND
STONES ARE FOREVER AN ALLEGIANCE
WITH GRAVITY. WHILE WE OURSELVES
DREAM OF RISING HOW TO HANDS
TOUCH AND THE BANDS WILL NEVER
BE BROKEN. PEOPLE COME FROM JULY
OR THE SCARS OF DAMAGE TO THE
COMFORT OF A POEM OR A PRAYER.
SO LET US KEEP OUR DISTANCE
ALWAYS FROM THOSE WHO THINK THEY
HAVE THE ANSWERS. LET US KEEP
COMPANY ALWAYS. WITH THOSE WHO
SAY LOOK. AND LAUGH IN
ASTONISHMENT AND ABOUT THEIR
HEADS. AMEN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
THE PLEDGE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG.
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR. THERE
ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE. WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS. AND NOTICES. SEEING
NO MEMBERS WISHING TO BE
RECOGNIZED. INTRODUCTION AND
FIRST READING A BILLS. WILL
READ. BILLS WILL BE DEEMED READ.
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING. FILE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. CYNICAL CURRENT
RESOLUTION 94. GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. SENATOR LAIRD, YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, UM
MADAM PRESIDENT. THIS IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF DR I RELENT FOR
APPOINTMENT TO THE COMMISSION ON
TEACHER CREDENTIALING FILE ITEM.
54 DOCTOR LET IS A PROFESSOR AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY'S GRADUATE
SCHOOL OF EDUCATION DESERVED IN
THE COMMISSION SEAT FOR A
FACULTY MEMBER FROM A COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY THAT GRANTS
BACCALAUREATE DEGREES. HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JANUARY 10TH. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I VOTE. SEEING NO
MEMBERS WISHING TO BE RECOGNIZED
WILL CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I'D
RATHER DEAL. I WANT TO LET UP BY
ASHBY. BACKINGS. AYE. BECKER,
SHAKESPEARE. AYE, BRADFORD. AYE
KBR. OH, I COURTESY I DOLLY.
DONE. HI, DURAZO. AYE, EGGMAN.
GLASER. GONZALEZ. I GROVE. NO. I
THOUGHT, OH, HI JONES. BLARED.
HI, LIMÓN. MCGUIRE I NEVER I
MEAN, AYE, NEWMAN. I WIN. NO
NEIL Ó. WHICH A CHILD VOGUE.
BUT YEAH, HI. PORTANTINO AYE,
ROTH. AYE, RUBIO. HI, SEYARTO.
SKINNER. AYE. SMALL GRIEVOUS.
AYE, STERN. I AM BERG. I HAVE HI
WIENER. I WELCOME I CALL THE
OPPOSITE MEMBERS, ALLEN. HI.
ASHBY. BECKER, DOLLY! JONES.
HELLO. PATROL BOAT. THEY ARE. 31
TO 2. THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. MOVING ON NOW TO
SENATE THIRD READING. SENATOR
DODD. SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
CYNIC CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT
NUMBER ONE BY SENATOR NEWMAN.
SENATE CONSTITUTIONAL CYNIC,
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION 96 BY
SENATOR DODD RELATIVE TO A
SISTER STATE ROLLING
RELATIONSHIP WITH RAVIV REGION,
UKRAINE. SENATOR DODD. THANK
YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS,
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
HISTORICALLY ADOPTED STRONG
RELATIONS WITH UKRAINE IN ORDER
TO PROMOTE GLOBAL PEACE AND
COOPERATION WHILE PAYING HOMAGE
TO OUR HISTORY IN BEING HOME TO
ONE OF THE LARGEST UKRAINIAN
COMMUNITIES IN THE UNITED STATES
. SCR 96 IS A SYMBOL OF MUTUAL
GOODWILL. AND ENCOURAGES
BILATERAL COOPERATION. THIS
RESOLUTION ALLOWS THE CREATION
OF A SISTER STATE RELATIONSHIP
WITH LA VIVE TO FOSTER CULTURAL
EXCHANGE AND ECONOMIC INNOVATION
. I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I VOTE
SENATOR MENU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
ÁP LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION AND
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. OBVIOUSLY WE'RE ALL
HYPER AWARE OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
WITH UKRAINE RIGHT NOW. AND JUST
YESTERDAY EARLIER THIS WEEK ON
THIS FLOOR, WE CELEBRATED KOREAN
AMERICAN DAY AND I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS AGAIN. I KNOW SOMETIMES
US MILITARY ASSISTANCE. OTHER
COUNTRIES CAN BE CONTROVERSIAL,
BUT KOREA IS A SHINING EXAMPLE
OF WHAT CAN HAPPEN WHEN US AID
IS PROVIDED AND KOREA'S CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE UNITED
STATES. I WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
THERE. I WOULD NOT BE STANDING
HERE BUT FOR THE SACRIFICES OF
36,000 AMERICAN TROOPS ALONG
TIME FROM AGO AND SO I KNOW THIS
IS NOT ABOUT OUR ASSISTANCE TO
UKRAINE, BUT I JUST WANT TO
EXPRESS THAT I STAND WITH
UKRAINE. AS I KNOW MANY OF THE
MEMBERS OF THIS LEGISLATURE DO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS WISHING
ME RECOGNIZE SENATOR DODD. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
EARLY SECRETARY WILL CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN AYE. TO GO. I
ACTUALLY TOÀN BE. ATKINS I
BECKER BLACK SPEAR. BY BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO. AYE. ORTEZ E. I
DOLLY. I DIED. I DURAZO. AYE,
EGGMAN. AYE, GLASER. HI
GONZALEZ. AYE, GROVE. I POTATO.
AYE, JONES. LAIRD. AYE, LIMÓN.
AYE, MCGUIRE. BY FAR I MEAN,
NEWMAN. I WIN. I KNEEL Ó. A
CHILD. BERG I VIDEO. I
PORTANTINO I BROUGHT AYE, RUBIO.
I SEE OUR TOE. I SKINNER AYE.
SMALL QUIVERS. STARTING I
HAMBURG. I WAS ROBBED. AYE,
WIENER. I WILL. AYE. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ASHBY,
BECKER. JONES. MEN. I DELYLAH.
SMALL GRIEVERS. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY BECKER JONES. AYE. HELLO.
COUNT IS 37 TO 0. THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED, MOVING ON NOW TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS WISHING
TO REMOVE ANYTHING FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING NONE
CLERK WILL READ. SENATE BILL
SEVEN CITY BUILT 382. AND
ACTIVATING TO REAL PROPERTY. THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL.
DOWLING. HI. I'M ROBERT GILMAN.
HI BETO. I ASHBY ATKINS. AYE,
BECKER. BLAKE SPEAR. BRADFORD. I
GOT ZERO. AYE. ORTEZ E. BYE.
DELI. AYE, DODD. HI, DURAZO. BY
ADMIN. HI, GLASER. I ALWAYS I
GROVE I DON'T KNOW. AYE. JONES.
AYE, LAIRD. AYE, LIMÓN. MCGUIRE
I MENTIONED BAR. I MEAN, NEWMAN.
HI, NGUYEN. I KNEW ALOT. BY
VIDEO. PORTANTINO ROD. AYE,
RUBIO. AYE, SEYARTO. AYE,
SKINNER. MEMBERS PLEASE SMALL
QUIVERS STERN. I AM BERG. I WA
BOB. AYE, WIENER. HI, WILK. HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHBY, BECKER, BLAKE SPEAR. AYE.
LIMÓN. MEN. I NEEDLE.
PORTANTINO. AYE.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ASHLEY. BECKER. LIMÓN AYE. 37 TO
0 CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED,
MOVING ON NOW TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. IMPORTANT TO YOU
KNOW. DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING?
NOTHING. UH. NOTHING TOO
IMPORTANT. THE. THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING 15 MINUTES AFTER THE
ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION AND ROOM
2200. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
PROBES. 2020 110 MINUTES
FOLLOWING SESSION, AND, UH CAN
RETURNING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. AND BEFORE I CALL
IN THE FIRST PERSON TO DO IT IN
GERMAN MEMORY, JUST REMINDER
MEMBERS BACK IN THE FIRST OF THE
YEAR CHATTER IS PRETTY LOUD OUT
THERE. IT'S HARD FOR PEOPLE TO
STAY FOCUSED AND THEN GET HERE
AND STAY HERE. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NOW MOVING ON TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. SENATOR
ATKINS PERFORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S HOWARD WAYNE.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT. IT
SEEMS WE'VE HAD A NUMBER OF
PASSINGS IN THE 39TH
SENATE-DISTRICT OVER THE OVER
OUR BREAK, SO I'VE HAD QUITE A
FEW. I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INDULGENCE THESE LAST FEW
WEEKS, BUT TODAY, UM, THANK YOU
FOR MENTIONING THE ADJOURNMENT,
MADAM PRESIDENT, I RISE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF THE
HONORABLE HOWARD WAYNE. WHO DIED
NOVEMBER 2ND ON HIS 75TH
BIRTHDAY. HOWARD WAS BORN TO
WILLIAM AND BLANCHE WAYNE ON
NOVEMBER 2ND 1948 IN FRESNO,
CALIFORNIA. THE FAMILY MOVED TO
SAN DIEGO WHEN HE WAS A TODDLER,
AND HOWARD NEVER LEFT HIS
ADOPTED HOMETOWN. HIS LIFELONG
INTEREST IN POLITICS BEGAN AT
AGE 11 WHEN AN UNCLE TOOK HIM
ONE NIGHT TO THE GALLERY OF THE
1960 DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
CONVENTION IN LOS ANGELES. WHEN
JOHN F. KENNEDY WAS NOMINATED
FOR PRESIDENT. AFTER ATTENDING
HOOVER HIGH SCHOOL IN CITY
HEIGHTS, HE ENROLLED AT WHAT WAS
THEN NAMED SAN DIEGO STATE
COLLEGE. WHEN HE WAS ONLY 15. HE
WAS AWARDED A BACHELOR OF ARTS
DEGREE IN HISTORY AND POLITICAL
SCIENCE IN 1969. HE EARNED A LAW
DEGREE FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
SAN DIEGO, WHERE HE SERVED AS
EDITOR OF THE LAW REVIEW IN
1972. HOWARD JOINED THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AS A DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL IN
1973, WHERE HE FOCUSED ON
CONSUMER PROTECTION CASES. HE
MET HIS WIFE, MARY LUNDBERG, IN
1982, AND THE COUPLE WERE
MARRIED IN 1988. MARY WENT TO
WORK AT THE U. S ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE. IN 1996. HOWARD
SUCCESSFULLY RAN FOR THE STATE
ASSEMBLY IN THE 78TH ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT AND SERVED THREE TERMS.
HE AUTHORED 60 BILLS THAT WERE
SIGNED INTO LAW AND APPROVED AND
UNAPPROVED CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT. HE SERVED AS THE
CHAIR OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE AND THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON BIOTECHNOLOGY. HE
WAS MOST PROUD OF SEEING ONE OF
HIS FIRST BILLS LANDMARK
LEGISLATION THAT CREATED A
COASTAL WATER QUALITY TESTING
PROGRAM SIGNED INTO LAW. HE
REQUIRED A LICENSE PLATE OR HE
ACQUIRED A LICENSE PLATE THAT
READ A B 411 TO COMMEMORATE THAT
ACCOMPLISHMENT. AFTER LEAVING
THE LEGISLATURE, HE RETURNED TO
HIS POSITION AS A DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL. HE WAS ALSO AN
ADJUNCT PROFESSOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO,
TEACHING A GRADUATE COURSE ON
ADVOCACY SKILLS AND STRATEGIES.
HOWARD AND HIS WIFE TRAVELED IN
2006 TO SOUTH AFRICA TO HELP
POST AND APARTHEID GOVERNMENT
ESTABLISHED A NEW LEGAL SYSTEM.
AFTER HIS RETIREMENT. HE WAS
SELECTED LAST YEAR TO SERVE ON
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY GRAND JURY
SPENDING 40 HOURS A WEEK ON
GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT WORK UNTIL
HE FELT ILL AS MANY VOLUNTEER
ACTIVITIES INCLUDED SERVING AS
VICE CHAIR OF THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY CHAIR OF
THE LINDA VISTA PLANNING GROUP
AND BEING AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
THE CLAREMONT TOWN COUNCIL, THE
LINDA VISTA TOWN COUNCIL. SARAH
MESA COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION AND
THE MISSION VALLEY COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATION. NOW ALL OF YOU WHO
GO TO COMMUNITY EVENTS. THINK OF
PLANNING COMMITTEES, TOWN
COUNCILS AND COMMUNITY
ASSOCIATIONS. HOWARD HAD A LOVE
OF THIS TYPE OF ENGAGEMENT AND
HE WAS ALWAYS LOOKED UP TO IN
THE COMMUNITY FOR HIS ADVICE,
HIS COUNSEL AND CERTAINLY HIS
LEADERSHIP. HE SURVIVED, AS I
SAID EARLIER BY HIS WIFE OF 35
YEARS, MARY LUMBER. HIS BROTHER,
ROBERT WAYNE OF SEATTLE, A LARGE
EXTENDED FAMILY OF SIBLINGS IN
LAW AND NUMEROUS NIECES AND
NEPHEWS. UM SORT OF APPROPRIATE
HOWARD CELEBRATION A LOT. I WAS
THE WEEKEND OF THE DEMOCRATIC
CONVENTION IN LOS ANGELES. WHICH
MAKES SENSE TO ME. SOME OF US
WERE NOT ABLE TO ATTEND. BUT WE
WERE REALLY FORTUNATE BECAUSE
YOU KNOW, HE WOULD HAVE EXPECTED
US TO GO DO OUR POLITICAL DUTY
AND MOST OF US DID. BUT WE WERE
FORTUNATE TO HAVE A FORMER
ELECTED OFFICIALS LYNN SHANK
CHRISTINE KEHOE, DENISE TO
CHENEY'S SUSAN DAVIS. AND D D.
ALBERT ALL IN ATTENDANCE AT HIS
SERVICE, SO THEY REPRESENTED
THOSE OF US WHO COULDN'T BE
THERE WELL AND HONOR OF A REALLY
GREAT PERSON. COLLEAGUES I ASK
THAT WE ADJOURNED TODAY IN THE
MEMORY OF HOWARD WAYNE, A
DEDICATED PUBLIC SERVANT, SAN
DIEGO AND THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE BENEFICIARIES OF
HIS PUBLIC SERVICE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE CAN BE POPULAR.
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED CORTEZ,
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
JOURNEY. THANK YOU, MR PRESIDENT
AND SENATORS. I RISE TO ADJOURN
THE MEMORY OF VICKI CHÁVEZ
LASTRA. A YOUNGER SISTER OF
CESAR CHAVEZ. VICKI PASSED AWAY
ON NOVEMBER 11TH 2023 AT THE AGE
OF 90. SHE WAS BORN IN 1932, THE
SECOND YOUNGEST OF FIVE CHILDREN
IN THAT FAMILY DURING THE EARLY
YEARS OF HER LIFE, OF COURSE,
UH, THOSE SIBLINGS GREW UP ON A
FAMILY HOMESTEADED NEAR YUMA,
ARIZONA. MOST OF US KNOW THAT
HISTORY, UM, ALONG WITH HER
BROTHER, OF COURSE, CESAR.
FAMILY LOST THAT FARM DURING THE
GREAT DEPRESSION. AND NOT ONLY
DID SHE ENDURED THE HARDSHIPS OF
FOLLOWING MIGRANT TRAILS AND
MIGRANT WORK ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
BUT SPENT HER EARLY CHILDHOOD IN
AND YOUNGEST YEARS. IN WHAT IS
NOW SENATE-DISTRICT 15 IN SAN
JOSE, CALIFORNIA. SHE CARRIED
THE TEACHINGS OF HER MOTHER
THROUGHOUT HER LIFE. ONE OF
THOSE WAS A COMMITMENT TO
NONVIOLENCE, AND PARTICULARLY
THAT IT'S NOT OUR PURPOSE ON
THIS EARTH TO BE VIOLENT AND
THAT WE SHOULD ALWAYS STRIVE.
LET'S DO OUR BEST IN TERMS OF
NONVIOLENT ACTION AND NONVIOLENT
RESISTANCE. AND IT MAKES SENSE
GIVEN HER BROTHERS WORK IN THAT
REGARD. THAT WAS A FAMILY
MANTRA. OF COURSE, MY OWN
GROWING UP WAS PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY ALLOWED ME TO
ENCOUNTER EACH AND EVERY ONE. OF
THE CHAVEZ FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
CONTINUE TO STAY ORGANIZED,
PARTICULARLY IN SAN JOSE TO THIS
DAY. ALTHOUGH RITA THE YOUNGEST
SISTER IS THE ONLY ONE LEFT
LIVING OF HER GENERATION. THOSE
WHO HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING
WITH VICKY NEVER SPOKE ANYTHING
BUT THE BEST OF HER. WE HAVE
SUFFERED A GREAT LOSS. HER DEATH
WAS ACTUALLY EXTREMELY
UNEXPECTED IN TRAGIC, UM NOT A
NATURAL DEATH. SURELY YOU
REMEMBER THAT SOMEONE WHO LOVED
TO DANCE WAS ALWAYS RAPPING AND
JOKING. IN HER MEMORY LIVES ON
THROUGH FAMILY FRIENDS CHURCH IN
MANY ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO HAVE
GOTTEN TO KNOW HER OVER THE
YEARS AS PART OF THE CHAVEZ
FAMILY VISION. THANK YOU AND I'D
BE HONORED IF THIS HOUSE WOULD
ADJOURN THE SESSION TODAY IN HER
MEMORY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, SENATOR. PLEASE BRING
HER NAME FORWARD. SO THE SENATE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE HER.
SENATOR BRADFORD, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR JOURNEY.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT
ARRIVES TODAY TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF AN AMAZING CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUENT OF MINE. MR LEONARD.
CLIFFORD TIBBS JR. WHO PASSED
AWAY ON THE NOVEMBER 22ND AT THE
AGE OF 89. HE WAS A LOVING SON,
HUSBAND, FATHER, GRANDFATHER.
AND A FRIEND TO MANY. LEONARD
WAS BORN ON MARCH 3RD. 1934 IN
LOS ANGELES, CALIFORNIA. HE WAS
THE ONLY SON OF A LULA LEE TIPS
AND LEONARD CLIFFORD TIPS.
SENIOR HIS FATHER WAS A
TRAILBLAZING GRADUATE OF THE USC
SCHOOL OF PHARMACY, AND HE WAS
ONE OF ONLY A FEW BLACK
PHARMACISTS IN L. A COUNTY. FOR
DECADES. LEONARD GRADUATED WITH
A DEGREE IN BUSINESS FROM U. C
L. A AND BEGAN A PROFESSIONAL
CAREER AND AEROSPACE
MANUFACTURING WITH THE MCDONNELL
DOUGLAS CORPORATION. AND HE
PLAYED A PIVOTAL ROLE IN THE 105
CENTURY FREEWAY AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION COMMITTEE. IF YOU
REMEMBER THAT FREEWAY FOR THOSE
IN L. A IT TOOK THE HOMES OF
MANY AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATINO
INDIVIDUALS. AS EARLY AS THE
SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES IN ORDER
TO CREATE THAT FREEWAY. LEONARD
GRADUATE, HE ALSO HAD A
ENTREPRENEUR, ENTREPRENEURIAL
SPIRIT TO LET HIM TO HAVE MANY,
MANY SUCCESSFUL BUSINESSES,
INCLUDING REAL ESTATE BROKER AND
INVESTOR. HE WAS THE OWNER OF
TIBBS TACOS, A CATERING BUSINESS
WITH SEVEN TRUCKS AND A RETAIL.
VENUE. HE THE COMBINATION OF HIS
BUSINESS ACUMEN AND ACTIVISM
CULTIVATED CULMINATED. I'M
SORRY, AND THE PRODUCTION OF A
NATIONAL HAIR CARE PRODUCT FOR
KINKY AND CURLY HAIR, HAIR HAIR
BETTER KNOWN AS THE WORLD OF
CURLS. HE WAS PERCEIVED AS A MAN
OF FEW WORDS, WHICH HE WAS YET
HE WAS ALWAYS CHARMING. AND
FRIENDLY. AND HAD A MASS AMOUNT
OF HOBBIES, DIVERSE HOBBIES. HE
LOVED GOLFING. THAT'S WHERE I
FIRST MET MR TIBBS ON THE GOLF
COURSE. HE HAD AN AMAZING BODY
ENJOYED BOATING, ENJOYED
FISHING. HE ENJOYED TRAVELING,
DO US AND IT'S RV AND
INTERNATIONALLY. UM, ALL AROUND
THE WORLD. HE HAD BEEN LEONARD
MET HIS LIFE PARTNER THAT IN THE
PERSON OF INGLEWOOD CITY COUNCIL
PERSON IN WEST BASIN MINISTER
BOARD MEMBER GLORIA GRAY IN 1999
AND WAS A STAUNCH SUPPORTER OF
EVERYTHING THAT SHE DID ALL OF
OUR COMMUNITY SERVICE EFFORTS
THROUGHOUT THEIR 25 YEARS
TOGETHER AND IN COUNCIL. MORE
WOMAN GRADES. WORDS LEONARD
CLIFFORD TIBBS JR WILL FOREVER
BE IN MY HEART AS SHE WAS IN HIS
HE LEFT AN INDELIBLE MARK ON THE
LIVES OF THOSE SHE TOUCHED, AND
HE WILL BE REMEMBERED BY HIS
DAUGHTER. HIS LIFE PARTNER AGAIN
. GLORIA GRAY MARRIED OF
RELATIVES AND FRIENDS. PLEASE
JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY AND THE
MEMORY OF LEONARD CLIFFORD TIBBS
, JR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE SENATE.
THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS.
SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR
. THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES HAVE A WONDERFUL
WEEKEND. OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION
IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY. JANUARY
22ND 2024 AT TWO PM WILL BE IN
RECESS UNTIL 330 AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY
AT TWO PM.